Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 41-year-old Peggy Carr was employed as a waitress at the Nicholas Family restaurant in South Central Florida. On October 23, 1988 she was working the Sunday morning shift when she started feeling unwell. A strong pain seared in the middle of her chest.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的本期节目说明。41岁的佩吉·卡尔（Peggy Carr）在佛罗里达州中南部的尼古拉斯家庭餐厅担任服务员。1988年10月23日，她在周日上午轮班时开始感到不适。她的胸口中央传来一阵剧烈的刺痛。
At first, Peggy thought she might be having a heart attack, but one of her regular customers assured her that couldn't be the case. Peggy's breathing and pulse were both in the normal range and the bright pink shade of her fingernails indicated she was receiving plenty of oxygen. As the day wore on, Peggy continued to feel sick. At lunchtime, her adult daughter Jelena arrived at the restaurant. The two worked together and Jelena was scheduled to cover the lunch shift. Jelena noticed something was wrong with her mother almost right away.
起初，佩吉以为自己可能心脏病发作了，但她的一位常客向她保证情况并非如此。佩吉的呼吸和脉搏都在正常范围内，她指甲呈现出的鲜粉色也表明她获得了充足的氧气。随着时间推移，佩吉感到越来越难受。午餐时间，她已成年的女儿杰琳娜（Jelena）来到餐厅。两人一起工作，杰琳娜原定要接手午餐班。杰琳娜几乎立刻就察觉到母亲出了问题。
Peggy, who rarely complained and was never unwell, told Jelena that her hands were numb and her legs were aching. Jelena touched her mother's hands. They were ice cold. She told Peggy to sit down and rest. Peggy did so, but the pain continued. Eventually, she decided to leave work early. Perhaps a nap at home would cure whatever was ailing her.
佩吉平时很少抱怨，也从未生过病，她告诉杰琳娜自己的手麻木了，腿也很疼。杰琳娜摸了摸母亲的手，发现冰凉刺骨。她让佩吉坐下休息。佩吉照做了，但疼痛仍在持续。最终，她决定提前下班。也许回家睡一觉就能治好她的病。
Later that afternoon, Peggy's husband, Perry Ellen Carr, better known as Pie, returned home from a hunting trip. He found Peggy sprawled on the living room sofa. As she greeted him, she looked sick and her voice sounded weak. The two had only been married for six months. It was a remarriage for both of them, the result of a whirlwind courtship. After the wedding, Peggy moved into Pie's home, a remote property surrounded by orange groves in the Florida town of Alturas.
那天下午晚些时候，佩吉的丈夫佩里·艾伦·卡尔（Perry Ellen Carr，人称“派”）结束狩猎旅行回到家。他发现佩吉瘫倒在客厅的沙发上。当她向他打招呼时，看起来病恹恹的，声音也很虚弱。两人结婚才六个月。这是他们两人的再婚，是一场闪电式恋爱的结果。婚后，佩吉搬进了派的家，那是一处位于佛罗里达州阿尔图拉斯（Alturas）镇、被橘子林环绕的偏远房产。
She brought two of her grown children with her, her eldest Jelena, 17-year-old Dwayne, and Jelena's two-year-old daughter. Peggy's other son, Alan, was stationed at a naval base in Tennessee. Two of Pie's children also lived at the home, 18-year-old Tammy and 16-year-old Travis. It was an adjustment as the large blended family got used to their new living arrangements, but Peggy and Pie did their best to make it work. When Pie found Peggy sick on the couch, his first instinct was to call his sister Carolyn, who was a nurse.
她带着两个已成年的孩子一起搬了过来，分别是长女杰琳娜、17岁的德韦恩（Dwayne）以及杰琳娜两岁的女儿。佩吉的另一个儿子艾伦（Alan）当时在田纳西州的一个海军基地服役。派的两个孩子，18岁的塔米（Tammy）和16岁的特拉维斯（Travis）也住在这里。这个重组大家庭在适应新的生活安排时经历了一些磨合，但佩吉和派都在尽力让生活步入正轨。当派发现佩吉病倒在沙发上时，他的第一反应是打电话给当护士的妹妹卡罗琳（Carolyn）。
Carolyn came over right away, but quickly gave Peggy the all-clear. All of her vitals seemed fine, although her blood pressure was slightly high. Peggy's daughter Jelena wasn't so sure. When she got home at around 9 o'clock that night, she found her mother lying in bed with her eyes tightly closed. Peggy's skin was deathly white, and her lips were badly chapped. She was so weak that she couldn't even get up to walk to the bathroom. In a whisper, Peggy told her daughter,
卡罗琳很快赶了过来，但很快就说佩吉没事。她所有的生命体征似乎都很正常，尽管血压略高。佩吉的女儿杰琳娜对此并不确定。那天晚上9点左右她回到家时，发现母亲躺在床上，双眼紧闭。佩吉的皮肤白得像死人一样，嘴唇干裂严重。她虚弱得连下床去洗手间都做不到。佩吉低声对女儿说：
You don't know how bad it hurts. Do you hear what I'm saying? I'm just hurting. Jelena found her stepfather Pie in the kitchen. We asked him to take her mother to the hospital. Pie refused. He said Peggy didn't want to go to a hospital and insisted she just had a virus. Jelena pleaded and offered to drive Peggy herself, yet Pie didn't budge.
你不知道这有多疼。你听到我说的了吗？我真的好疼。杰琳娜在厨房找到了继父派。我们请求他带母亲去医院。派拒绝了。他说佩吉不想去医院，并坚持认为她只是得了病毒感染。杰琳娜苦苦哀求，并提出亲自开车送佩吉去，但派依然不为所动。
A little while later, he changed his mind. He carried Peggy into his car and set out for Bartow Memorial Hospital, which was about 11 miles away. Jelena followed behind in her own vehicle. Once they reached the emergency room, a doctor performed a brief examination of Peggy. Even having her arm touched was excruciating. In describing her symptoms, Peggy stated, I feel like I'm on fire. The doctors were at a loss as to what was wrong.
过了一会儿，他改变了主意。他把佩吉抱进车里，出发前往约11英里外的巴托纪念医院（Bartow Memorial Hospital）。杰琳娜开车跟在后面。到达急诊室后，医生对佩吉进行了简短的检查。即使是触碰她的手臂也让她痛苦不堪。在描述症状时，佩吉说：“我觉得自己像是在火里烧一样。”医生们对她的病情束手无策。
Doctors failed to uncover a diagnosis, prompting one doctor to suggest Peggy's symptoms might be psychosomatic, caused by a mental factor rather than a physical one. This theory upset Peggy. Whatever her illness was, she knew it hadn't been caused by stress or her imagination. Peggy spent three days in hospital, and although no one could figure out what had made her sick, she soon began to improve. She became well enough to sit up in bed, drink coffee, and even eat by herself. When she complained about the quality of the hospital's food, her daughter Jelena knew
医生未能查出病因，导致其中一名医生认为佩吉的症状可能是心因性的，是由心理因素而非生理因素引起的。这一理论让佩吉感到不安。无论她得了什么病，她都知道这绝不是压力或想象力造成的。佩吉在医院住了三天，虽然没人能查出她生病的原因，但她很快开始好转。她身体状况好转，可以坐起来喝咖啡，甚至能自己进食。当她抱怨医院的饭菜质量时，女儿杰琳娜知道
she was getting better. Peggy's signs of improvement prompted the doctors to send her home. The next evening, Pie's sister, Carolyn, brought over fried chicken for the family. She portioned it out and served it alongside glasses of Coca-Cola. The next morning, 16-year-old Travis and 17-year-old Dwayne felt sick. They figured it was likely a hangover, as they'd had a big night out with friends. But when their feet began to tingle, it became clear they were suffering the same symptoms as Peggy.
她正在康复。佩吉好转的迹象促使医生让她出院回家。第二天晚上，派的妹妹卡罗琳带了炸鸡给全家人吃。她把炸鸡分好，并配上可乐。第二天早上，16岁的特拉维斯和17岁的德韦恩感到不适。他们以为这可能是宿醉，因为他们前一天晚上和朋友玩得很疯。但当他们的脚开始发麻时，很明显他们出现了和佩吉一样的症状。
Soon, the boys felt a burning sensation inside their bodies. Peggy's symptoms also started worsening. At 7.30 the following night, she was let away in an ambulance. This time, Peggy was taken to Winterhaven Hospital, where she was examined by a neurologist named Dr. T. Richard Hosler. Dr. Hosler asked Peggy to try to keep her eyes shut. He then tried to open them. Peggy couldn't resist, and her eyes opened easily.
很快，男孩们感到体内有一种灼烧感。佩吉的症状也开始恶化。第二天晚上7点30分，她被救护车带走。这一次，佩吉被送往温特黑文医院（Winterhaven Hospital），在那里她接受了一位名叫T·理查德·霍斯勒（T. Richard Hosler）的神经科医生的检查。霍斯勒医生让佩吉试着闭上眼睛，然后他试图睁开她的眼睛。佩吉无法抵抗，眼睛很容易就被睁开了。
This was unusual for a healthy adult. She was also extremely sensitive to touch, and her mouth was filled with ulcerations. Peggy told the doctor that her feet felt like they were on fire. Dr. Hosler believed Peggy could have been poisoned by some kind of heavy metal. Then he found out that two of the family's children were also starting to exhibit symptoms that strengthened his conviction. He asked that Travis and Dwayne be brought in for observation as well. According to Pye, the family's property hadn't been sprayed with any insecticides recently,
这对于一个健康的成年人来说是不正常的。她对触碰也极其敏感，嘴里长满了溃疡。佩吉告诉医生，她的脚感觉像是在火里烧。霍斯勒医生认为佩吉可能中了某种重金属毒。随后他发现家里有两个孩子也开始出现症状，这加强了他的判断。他要求将特拉维斯和德韦恩也带进来观察。据派说，家里的房产最近没有喷洒过任何杀虫剂，
and there was no reason a heavy metal should have been present in their home. Nonetheless, Dr. Hosler decided to have Peggy tested for lead, arsenic, and mercury poisoning. These three heavy metals were the most common that people could encounter. Dr. Hosler also decided to test for a fourth kind of poison, thallium. Colourless, odourless, and tasteless, thallium was once widely used throughout the United States as a rat poison and pesticide. And in 1972, the US banned its use due to safety concerns. Thallium is so highly toxic that mild contact with skin alone can be extremely dangerous.
而且家里没有理由会出现重金属。尽管如此，霍斯勒医生还是决定对佩吉进行铅、砷和汞中毒检测。这三种重金属是人们最容易接触到的。霍斯勒医生还决定检测第四种毒药——铊。铊无色、无味、无臭，曾在美国被广泛用作老鼠药和杀虫剂。1972年，美国因安全考虑禁止了其使用。铊的毒性极高，仅与皮肤轻微接触就可能极其危险。
The fact that thallium was illegal made it rare, and therefore extremely unlikely that Peggy Carr could have encountered it in her home. Yet Dr. Hosler was intrigued by Peggy's description of feeling like she was burning to death. One of his colleagues also noticed that Peggy's hair had started falling out. Both of these symptoms fit perfectly with thallium poisoning. Peggy's health deteriorated rapidly. That evening she was transferred to the intensive care unit where she lay in bed surrounded by machines.
铊的非法性使其变得罕见，因此佩吉·卡尔几乎不可能在家中接触到它。然而，霍斯勒医生对佩吉描述的“感觉像是在被活活烧死”很感兴趣。他的一位同事还注意到佩吉的头发开始脱落。这两个症状都与铊中毒完全吻合。佩吉的健康状况迅速恶化。那天晚上，她被转入重症监护室，躺在被机器包围的病床上。
Tubes were attached to her nose and mouth to enable her to breathe. Peggy's wrists had been tied down so she couldn't pull the tubes out. She lost the ability to speak and open her eyes. But she was still conscious and aware of when she was being spoken to. Both of Peggy's parents had been deaf and she had learnt sign language as a child. Now incapacitated in hospital, she was able to use signing as a way to communicate. Peggy's sister Shirley drove to Florida from her home in Alabama to see Peggy. When she asked her now unrecognisable sister if she knew who Shirley was, Peggy signed
她的鼻腔和口腔插着管子以维持呼吸。佩吉的手腕被绑住，以免她拔掉管子。她失去了说话和睁眼的能力。但她仍然清醒，知道有人在跟她说话。佩吉的父母都是聋哑人，她从小就学会了手语。现在在医院丧失行动能力的她，能够用手语进行交流。佩吉的妹妹雪莉（Shirley）从阿拉巴马州的家中开车赶到佛罗里达看望她。当她问起现在已经认不出来的姐姐是否知道她是雪莉时，佩吉用手语比划道：
Yes. Peggy, how are you feeling, Shirley asked. Peggy signed again. I heard. The results of Peggy's tests came back quickly. As Dr. Hossler had suspected, she tested positive for thallium. In fact, the amount of thallium in her system exceeded the amount the lab could measure. Dwayne and Travis tested positive for thallium too, but at much lower levels.
“是的。”“佩吉，你感觉怎么样？”雪莉问。佩吉再次比划道：“我听到了。”佩吉的检测结果很快出来了。正如霍斯勒医生所怀疑的那样，她的铊检测呈阳性。事实上，她体内的铊含量超过了实验室所能测量的上限。德韦恩和特拉维斯的铊检测也呈阳性，但含量低得多。
With the amount of thallium Peggy had in her body, doctors knew it would be impossible for her to recover. The thallium was causing her nerves to waste away and die. Peggy's symptoms would soon progress to paralysis, coma and death. In 1988, it was almost unheard of for someone to experience thallium poisoning in the United States. It simply wasn't a heavy metal that people could encounter in their day-to-day lives. Dr. Hossler was certain that Peggy's poisoning wasn't a tragic accident.
鉴于佩吉体内的铊含量，医生们知道她不可能康复了。铊正在导致她的神经萎缩和坏死。佩吉的症状很快会发展为瘫痪、昏迷和死亡。在1988年，在美国发生铊中毒几乎是闻所未闻的。这根本不是人们在日常生活中会接触到的重金属。霍斯勒医生确信佩吉的中毒绝非一场悲剧性的意外。
It must be a deliberate and malicious act. The doctor broke the news to Peggy's husband, Pye, who in turn told Peggy. As she lay in a hospital bed with her eyes closed and machines breathing for her, Pye said, Peggy, do you know why you're here? No, Peggy signed in reply. Peggy, you've been poisoned, Pye told her. All Peggy could do in response was sign the same word over and over.
这一定是一起蓄意且恶毒的行为。医生将这个消息告诉了佩吉的丈夫派，派随后又告诉了佩吉。当她闭着眼睛躺在病床上，靠机器维持呼吸时，派说：“佩吉，你知道你为什么在这里吗？”“不知道，”佩吉用手语回答。“佩吉，你中毒了，”派告诉她。佩吉能做的回应只有一遍又一遍地比划同一个词。
Why? Why? Why? Dr. Hossler informed Pye that he believed someone had tried to poison his family and that, quote, somehow you were spared. Pye was silent for a moment. He then remarked, I don't think anyone dislikes us enough to do that.
“为什么？为什么？为什么？”霍斯勒医生通知派，他认为有人试图毒害他的家人，并且“不知何故你幸免于难”。派沉默了片刻。然后他评论道：“我不认为有人讨厌我们到那种地步。”
Dwayne and Travis continued to get sicker, while Peggy became completely unresponsive. Three days after Peggy arrived at Winterhaven Hospital, police attempted to interview her to see if she knew who might want to harm her. But she was unable to do anything except squeeze her sister's hand. The thallium eventually caused Peggy's muscles to become entirely paralyzed. She lost the ability to close her eyes and simply stared up blankly. Unable to blink, it was inevitable that ulcers would form on her corneas. The doctors had to sew her eyes shut to protect them.
德韦恩和特拉维斯的病情继续恶化，而佩吉则完全没有反应。佩吉到达温特黑文医院三天后，警方试图采访她，看她是否知道谁可能想伤害她。但她除了握住妹妹的手之外，什么也做不了。铊最终导致佩吉的肌肉完全瘫痪。她失去了闭眼的能力，只能茫然地盯着上方。由于无法眨眼，角膜溃疡的形成是不可避免的。医生不得不缝合她的眼睛以保护它们。
Within weeks, Peggy fell into a coma. While Dwayne and Travis eventually made full recoveries, Peggy's family came to accept that she would never get better. They continued to visit and talk to her all the time. On Friday, March 3, 1989, about four and a half months after Peggy first became sick, the decision was made to switch off her life support system. Peggy's two eldest children, Jelena and Dallin, had their own suspicions as to who would want to kill their mother.
几周内，佩吉陷入了昏迷。虽然德韦恩和特拉维斯最终完全康复，但佩吉的家人不得不接受她永远不会好转的事实。他们一直去探望她，并不停地跟她说话。1989年3月3日星期五，在佩吉第一次生病约四个半月后，家人决定关闭她的生命维持系统。佩吉的两个大孩子，杰琳娜和达林（Dallin），对谁会想杀害他们的母亲有自己的怀疑。
When Peggy remarried, her children were initially pleased for her. They felt she deserved some joy after her other relationships hadn't worked out and Pie seemed to make her happy. But as the months went by, Peggy experienced some niggling doubts. The couple's children had initially gotten along well, but they soon started to fight with each other. Pie was employed at a phosphate mine and worked incredibly long hours. Peggy began to suspect that something else was going on.
当佩吉再婚时，她的孩子们起初为她感到高兴。他们觉得她在之前的感情失败后理应得到一些快乐，而且派似乎让她很幸福。但随着时间的推移，佩吉产生了一些细微的怀疑。这对夫妇的孩子们起初相处得很好，但很快就开始互相争吵。派在一家磷酸盐矿工作，工作时间极长。佩吉开始怀疑还有其他事情发生。
One night, when Pie said he had to work late, Peggy and Jelena decided to investigate. They got into Jelena's car and drove out to the mine. Upon their arrival, there were only two cars in the parking lot. One was Pie's. The other belonged to a former girlfriend of his. Pie was having an affair. Peggy left the family home with her children and granddaughter. She left a note for Pie that read,
一天晚上，当派说他必须加班时，佩吉和杰琳娜决定一探究竟。她们坐上杰琳娜的车，开车去了矿场。到达后，停车场里只有两辆车。一辆是派的，另一辆属于他的前女友。派有外遇了。佩吉带着她的孩子和孙女离开了家。她给派留了一张字条，上面写着：
I do love you very, very much. Right now I'm at the point that I don't really know how you feel. I told you I could handle anything as long as I had you. Now I'm not sure. I'm going to give you some time to think about us. I can't live like we have been. No respect from the kids, not talking, not caring. I love you and want to be your wife.
“我确实非常非常爱你。现在我到了一个地步，我真的不知道你的感受。我告诉过你，只要有你在，我什么都能应付。现在我不确定了。我要给你一些时间来考虑我们。我无法过我们现在这样的生活。孩子们不尊重我，我们不交流，也不关心彼此。我爱你，想做你的妻子。”
Key word is wife. I don't know if this is right or not what I'm doing but I don't know what else to do. I can't imagine living without you but I can if you don't want me. There's no question in my mind whether or not I want you and love you. Is there a question in your mind? I'll be okay if anyone is interested. I love you with all my heart. Peggy
“关键词是妻子。我不知道我这样做是对还是错，但我不知道还能做什么。我无法想象没有你的生活，但如果你不想要我，我也能过。我心里毫无疑问我是否想要你、爱你。你心里有疑问吗？如果有人感兴趣的话，我会没事的。我全心全意地爱你。佩吉”
A few days later on Thursday October 20, the couple reconciled and Peggy moved back home. That same day, Pie left for a previously scheduled hunting trip which would keep him away all weekend. When he returned on Sunday October 23, Peggy was sick on the couch. Jelena had been disturbed by Pie's initial reluctance to take her mother to the hospital. She immediately began to wonder if he was behind Peggy's illness. Jelena confided in a co-worker that she thought Pie and his sister Carolyn were poisoning her mother.
几天后的10月20日星期四，两人和解，佩吉搬回了家。同一天，派出发去参加预定的狩猎旅行，整个周末都不在家。当他在10月23日星期日回来时，佩吉病倒在沙发上。杰琳娜对派起初不愿带母亲去医院感到不安。她立刻开始怀疑他是否是佩吉生病的幕后黑手。杰琳娜向一位同事吐露，她认为派和他的妹妹卡罗琳正在毒害她的母亲。
Carolyn soon came to share his sister's suspicions. The siblings weren't alone. Larry Doubly, who was Peggy's ex-husband and Dwayne's father, was spending time at the hospital with his sick son. He overheard Pie being questioned about the poisoning by a police officer. Afterwards, he noticed that Pie was trembling all over. On another occasion, Larry Doubly was outside the hospital room where both teenage boys were staying when he heard a commotion from inside.
卡罗琳很快也开始分享她妹妹的怀疑。这对兄妹并不孤单。佩吉的前夫、德韦恩的父亲拉里·多布利（Larry Doubly）当时正在医院陪伴生病的儿子。他无意中听到一名警察在审问派关于中毒的事情。事后，他注意到派浑身发抖。另一次，拉里·多布利在两个十几岁男孩居住的病房外，听到里面传来一阵骚动。
He rushed in and saw Pie and Carolyn standing there as Pie's son Travis screamed, Larry help me, they're trying to kill me. Carolyn reassured him that they weren't trying to harm him. Larry had noticed how Carolyn brought food to the hospital for the teens and wondered about her motives. He claimed that Peggy had told him Pie had taken out life insurance policies for her and the boys. 80,000 for Peggy and 60,000 for each boy.
他冲进去，看到派和卡罗琳站在那里，派的儿子特拉维斯尖叫道：“拉里，救救我，他们想杀我。”卡罗琳安慰他说他们并没有想伤害他。拉里注意到卡罗琳是如何给孩子们带食物到医院的，并对她的动机产生了怀疑。他声称佩吉曾告诉他，派为她和孩子们购买了人寿保险。佩吉8万美元，每个孩子6万美元。
Larry Doubly mentioned another troubling story. One day, several family members were gathered around discussing thallium. One person speculated that it may have come from the phosphate mines. Pie's ex-wife, who was present, faced Pie and said, You've been working at Silver City Mines all these years. They've got two chemist labs out there. Do you all have any of that shit out there? Do you know anything about this?
拉里·多布利提到了另一个令人不安的故事。一天，几位家庭成员聚在一起讨论铊。有人推测它可能来自磷酸盐矿。在场的派的前妻面对派说：“你这些年来一直在银城矿（Silver City Mines）工作。他们那里有两个化学实验室。你们那里有那种东西吗？你知道这件事吗？”
According to Larry, Pie told his ex-wife, You shut your goddamn mouth. Other people, including Dr. Hossler and the family's minister, told investigators that they didn't find Pie car suspicious at all. They saw how Pie spent weeks by Peggy's side, talking to her constantly, even when she was unresponsive. The entire car household was tested for thallium. Everyone except Pie's daughter Tammy had traces of the heavy metal in their system.
据拉里说，派对他的前妻说：“你给我闭上你的臭嘴。”其他人，包括霍斯勒医生和该家庭的牧师，告诉调查人员他们一点也不觉得派·卡尔可疑。他们看到派如何在佩吉身边陪伴了数周，即使在她没有反应时也一直跟她说话。整个卡尔家都接受了铊检测。除了派的女儿塔米外，每个人的体内都有这种重金属的痕迹。
Even Pie had enough in his body to make a smaller person unwell. But due to his tall stature and larger frame, Pie only experienced some slight aches and pains. The fact that Pie had also absorbed thallium made detectives less inclined to suspect him. The fastest way they could get to the bottom of the crime was to figure out how and where the family had been exposed to thallium. This would also help calm the residents of ordinarily sleepy Alturas, who were panicking after learning about the poisoning.
甚至派的体内也有足够的量让一个体型较小的人不适。但由于他身材高大，体格健壮，派只感到了一些轻微的疼痛。派也吸收了铊这一事实使侦探们不太倾向于怀疑他。他们查清案件真相的最快方法是弄清楚这家人是如何以及在哪里接触到铊的。这也将有助于平息阿尔图拉斯这个通常安静的小镇居民的恐慌，他们在得知中毒事件后感到惊慌失措。
Just in case the exposure had been accidental, environmental officials started testing the fields, orange groves and water wells surrounding the car property. These tests came up negative for thallium. Investigators weren't surprised as the car's nearest neighbours drank from the same well as them and hadn't been sick at all. Dwayne and Travis reported having seen a tractor spraying pesticides in the area. It was tracked down and ruled out as well. Pie car's workplace was searched and a tin of rat poison was recovered.
为了以防万一接触是偶然的，环境官员开始测试卡尔家周围的田地、橘子林和水井。这些测试结果显示铊呈阴性。调查人员并不感到惊讶，因为卡尔家最近的邻居喝的是同一口井的水，却一点事也没有。德韦恩和特拉维斯报告说看到一辆拖拉机在该地区喷洒杀虫剂。它也被追踪到并排除了嫌疑。派·卡尔的工作场所被搜查，并发现了一罐老鼠药。
It tested negative for thallium. Detectives turned their attention to the car's home. They performed multiple sweeps of the house, carding off item after item to be sent off to a laboratory for testing. Testing resulted. Then, during a final inspection of the house in November 1988, one detective noticed some broken glass on the kitchen floor. Kneeling down, he looked beneath a nearby counter.
经检测，铊呈阴性。侦探们将注意力转向了卡尔家。他们对房子进行了多次搜查，将一件又一件物品装箱送往实验室进行检测。检测结果出来了。然后，在1988年11月对房子的最后一次检查中，一名侦探注意到厨房地板上有一些碎玻璃。他跪下来，看向附近的一个柜台下方。
There was a rubbish bin underneath and behind that was a carton filled with glass bottles of Coca-Cola. There were eight 16-ounce bottles in total. Three of them were empty, while four were full and unopened. The final bottle had a broken neck, which was presumably where the broken glass had come from. The Coke bottles were tested by the Florida Department of Health and Rehabilitative Services. Their laboratories found between half a gram and one gram of thallium in each of the full
下面有一个垃圾桶，后面是一个装满可口可乐玻璃瓶的纸箱。总共有八个16盎司的瓶子。其中三个是空的，四个是满的且未开封。最后一个瓶子瓶颈破裂，这大概就是碎玻璃的来源。这些可乐瓶由佛罗里达州卫生与康复服务部进行了检测。他们的实验室在每个满瓶中发现了0.5克到1克不等的铊。
bottles. One gram was enough to kill an adult, and a less was required to kill a child. The empty bottles all had thallium residue at the base. Six years earlier, in 1982, seven people died in the Chicago metropolitan area after taking Tylenol capsules that had been laced with potassium cyanide and then sold on pharmacy shelves. As covered in episode 118 of Case File, the case became known as the Chicago Tylenol Murders. The story made national headlines and had huge ripple effects throughout the US.
一克足以杀死一个成年人，杀死一个孩子所需的量更少。所有空瓶子的底部都有铊残留。六年前的1982年，芝加哥大都会区有七人在服用被掺入氰化钾并放在药店货架上出售的泰诺胶囊后死亡。正如《案件档案》（Case File）第118集所报道的那样，该案被称为“芝加哥泰诺谋杀案”。这个故事登上了全国头条，并在全美产生了巨大的连锁反应。
Investigators on the Peggy Car Case had to consider whether they were dealing with a similar crime. There were no obvious signs that the Coke bottles had been tampered with. There were no fingerprints, nor did the bottle caps have any scratches on them. In the full bottles, the liquid appeared to be the same color and consistency as a regular bottle of Coke. Although there were no reports of anyone else suffering from thallium poisoning, investigators visited the nearest Coca-Cola bottling plant in Tampa, Florida.
佩吉·卡尔案的调查人员必须考虑他们是否在处理一起类似的犯罪。没有明显的迹象表明可乐瓶被篡改过。没有指纹，瓶盖上也没有划痕。在满瓶中，液体的颜色和浓度看起来与普通可乐瓶一样。虽然没有其他人铊中毒的报告，但调查人员还是走访了位于佛罗里达州坦帕市最近的可口可乐装瓶厂。
After inspecting the way the plant's machinery operated and how the bottles were distributed, they concluded that it would have been impossible for anyone to place eight poisoned bottles on the assembly line and have them put in the same carton. It appeared that the car family had been deliberately targeted with a carton that was tampered with after being bought at a store. No one in the family knew where the bottles had come from. They just appeared under the counter one day. Although the family usually purchased Pepsi brand cola instead of Coke, nobody thought
在检查了工厂机器的运作方式以及瓶子的分发方式后，他们得出结论，任何人都不可能在装配线上放置八个被下毒的瓶子，并让它们被装进同一个纸箱里。看起来卡尔一家是被蓄意针对的，纸箱是在从商店购买后被篡改的。家里没有人知道这些瓶子是从哪里来的。它们有一天就出现在柜台下面。虽然这家人通常购买百事可乐而不是可乐，但没人多想。
anything of it. Pye recalled that when Peggy had first become sick, he'd made himself a whiskey and Coke from one of the bottles. Pye's sister Caroline said she had poured a glass of Coke for Peggy after she returned from her first hospital visit. Believing Peggy had some kind of virus, Caroline encouraged her to keep her fluids up. But all this had done was increase the levels of thallium in Peggy's body. Caroline had also given Dwayne and Travis Cokes when they complained of feeling sick.
派回忆说，佩吉刚生病时，他曾用其中一个瓶子给自己调了一杯威士忌加可乐。派的妹妹卡罗琳说，她在佩吉第一次从医院回来后，给佩吉倒了一杯可乐。卡罗琳认为佩吉得了某种病毒，鼓励她多补充水分。但这只会增加佩吉体内的铊含量。卡罗琳在德韦恩和特拉维斯抱怨身体不适时，也给了他们可乐。
The bottles were sent to FBI experts. When they examined the bottle caps under an extremely powerful microscope, they detected tiny scratch marks on a diagonal angle. This indicated that someone had removed the caps with something like a screwdriver or can opener, put the thallium inside, then re-facened the caps. Although the liquid in the full bottles looked like regular Coca-Cola, testing revealed it had lost some of its carbonation. Whoever had poisoned the bottles knew exactly what they were doing.
瓶子被送到了联邦调查局（FBI）的专家手中。当他们用功能极其强大的显微镜检查瓶盖时，发现了对角线上的微小划痕。这表明有人用螺丝刀或开罐器之类的东西取下了瓶盖，放入铊，然后重新盖上。虽然满瓶中的液体看起来像普通可乐，但检测显示它失去了一些碳酸。无论谁给瓶子下毒，都非常清楚自己在做什么。
There was no sign of tampering that would be visible to the human eye. It also would have taken some work for them to figure out the correct ratio of thallium to use to ensure the liquid didn't change colour or overflow from the bottle. While Peggy's two oldest children still suspected Pye and Caroline, detectives were less sure. They hadn't found any evidence of the supposed life insurance policies Pye had taken out on his wife, son and stepson, nor did they find Pye or Caroline at all suspicious. They also found it extremely unlikely that Pye would have put his entire family at risk if he was looking to end his relationship with his new wife.
没有任何肉眼可见的篡改迹象。他们还需要做一些工作来计算出铊的正确比例，以确保液体不会变色或从瓶子里溢出。虽然佩吉的两个大孩子仍然怀疑派和卡罗琳，但侦探们不太确定。他们没有找到任何证据证明派为他的妻子、儿子和继子购买了所谓的巨额人寿保险，也没有发现派或卡罗琳有任何可疑之处。他们还认为，如果派想结束与新妻子的关系，他不太可能让全家人都处于危险之中。
Pye's daughter Tammy was the only member of the family who didn't test positive for traces of thallium. This led to her being questioned as a possible suspect as well. She told investigators that she only drank diet sodas, which was why she hadn't consumed any of the coke. Pye's ruled out all of the family members as possible suspects. It seemed increasingly likely that someone outside of the household was responsible. Whoever it was had tampered with the bottles and somehow snuck them into the house when
派的女儿塔米是家里唯一一个铊检测呈阴性的成员。这导致她也被作为嫌疑人审问。她告诉调查人员，她只喝健怡汽水，这就是她没有喝可乐的原因。派排除了所有家庭成员作为嫌疑人的可能。越来越有可能的是，家庭以外的某个人负有责任。无论那个人是谁，他都篡改了瓶子，并以某种方式在家里没人的时候把它们偷偷放进了屋里。
no one was home. Pye Carr found it hard to believe that anyone would want to harm his family in such a way. As far as he knew, they didn't have any enemies. But Peggy's sister surely told investigators something that immediately caught their attention. Four months before the poisonings, in June 1988, the Carr family had received a threatening letter. When Pye was asked about the letter, he said he'd forgotten all about it. However, at the detective's request, he managed to locate it.
派·卡尔很难相信会有人想以这种方式伤害他的家人。据他所知，他们没有任何敌人。但佩吉的妹妹雪莉告诉调查人员的一件事立刻引起了他们的注意。在中毒事件发生四个月前的1988年6月，卡尔一家收到了一封威胁信。当派被问及这封信时，他说他已经完全忘记了。然而，在侦探的要求下，他设法找到了它。
The envelope had been addressed to Pye Carr. Below was the family's address and inside was a yellow post-it note with a typed message. You and all your so-called family have two weeks to move out of Florida forever or else you all die. This is no joke. The family had all gathered together to study the note. The writer had misspelled Pye's first name as P-I-E instead of P-Y-E. Given that everyone who knew him knew the correct spelling, Pye and Peggy's children
信封上写着派·卡尔的名字。下面是家庭地址，里面是一张黄色的便利贴，上面有打印的信息：“你和你所有所谓的家人有两周时间永远搬出佛罗里达，否则你们都得死。这不是开玩笑。”全家人聚在一起研究这张纸条。写信的人把派的名字拼错了，拼成了P-I-E而不是P-Y-E。鉴于所有认识他的人都知道正确的拼写，派和佩吉的孩子们
dismissed the letter as a sick joke. But Peggy took it seriously. She told her kids to be extra careful, saying, I want you to stay close to the house. Be nice to people. This could be real. In the spring of 1989, 33-year-old Sherry Gwynne came across a newspaper advertisement for an intriguing event.
把这封信当作一个恶作剧。但佩吉很认真。她告诉孩子们要格外小心，说：“我希望你们待在离家近的地方。对人友善点。这可能是真的。”1989年春天，33岁的雪莉·格温（Sherry Gwynne）在报纸上看到了一则关于一个有趣活动的广告。
It was a murder mystery weekend, taking place at a hotel in Winterhaven. The event was being hosted by a couple who were leaders in the Polk County chapter of Mensa, an organization for people who possess an IQ in the top 2% of the population. Sherry typed a letter to one of the event's hosts, whose name was George Trepal. Dear George, this letter is to request further information on the upcoming Mensa murder weekend. As I am considering moving my home to this quiescent county, I am compelled to find some type of stimulating entertainment. Although I am acquainted with the renowned Mensa organization, never before have I been
那是一个谋杀之谜周末，在温特黑文的一家酒店举行。该活动由一对夫妇主办，他们是门萨（Mensa）波尔克县分会的领导人，门萨是一个为智商处于人口前2%的人设立的组织。雪莉给其中一位活动主持人写了一封信，他的名字叫乔治·特雷帕尔（George Trepal）。“亲爱的乔治，这封信是为了索取关于即将举行的门萨谋杀周末的更多信息。由于我正在考虑搬家到这个宁静的县，我迫切需要寻找某种刺激的娱乐活动。虽然我熟悉著名的门萨组织，但我以前从未
involved in a lifestyle that would permit such endeavors. My background consists of years of dedicated service to my perfidious mate, who took his thriving career and moved upwards and onwards alone. A weekend filled with intrigue and intellect could be just what the doctor ordered. Sincerely, Sharon Sherry Gwynne. Shortly after sending the letter, Sherry received a registration form and a brochure about the event in the mail. On Friday, April 14, she arrived at the Winterhaven Holiday Inn to attend the murder mystery weekend.
参与过允许此类活动的社交生活。我的背景包括多年来对我那背信弃义的伴侣的奉献，他带着他蒸蒸日上的事业独自向上和向前发展了。一个充满阴谋和智慧的周末可能正是医生所要求的。诚挚地，莎伦·雪莉·格温。”寄出信后不久，雪莉就在邮件中收到了注册表和关于该活动的宣传册。4月14日星期五，她抵达温特黑文假日酒店参加谋杀之谜周末。
At the registration desk, she met 39 year old George Trepal, a small man with thinning hair and thick glasses. He handed Sherry a pamphlet of information about the weekend. For the murder mystery game, guests were assigned to different roles such as bystander, victim or murderer. At some point, the victims would pretend to be killed. Other attendees would have to observe the events that followed closely, looking for clues as to who the murderers were.
在登记处，她遇到了39岁的乔治·特雷帕尔，一个头发稀疏、戴着厚眼镜的小个子男人。他递给雪莉一本关于周末活动的小册子。在谋杀之谜游戏中，客人们被分配到不同的角色，如旁观者、受害者或凶手。在某个时刻，受害者会假装被杀。其他参加者必须密切观察随后的事件，寻找谁是凶手的线索。
Sherry Gwynne was given the role of bystander. Over the course of the weekend, Sherry struck up a couple of conversations with the George Trepal. George spent his time organising men's aggettogethers, programming computers and working as a freelance technical writer. His wife and co-host, Diana, worked as a doctor. Sherry learned that the couple were thinking about selling their home. Her interest immediately peaked.
雪莉·格温被分配了旁观者的角色。在周末期间，雪莉与乔治·特雷帕尔进行了几次交谈。乔治把时间花在组织门萨聚会、编写计算机程序和担任自由技术作家上。他的妻子兼联合主持人戴安娜（Diana）是一名医生。雪莉得知这对夫妇正在考虑卖掉他们的房子。她的兴趣立刻被激发了。
Sherry was in the process of divorcing her lawyer husband and would be able to buy a new place to live as part of the settlement. George invited Sherry to come over and look at the house anytime that suited. A few days later, Sherry headed out to George Trepal's property for a tour. George lived in an isolated area of Alturus amongst some orange groves. The house was decorated with 1970s decor, including yellow curtains and orange cabinets. It had a library crammed with books on scientific subjects. The main bedroom was also full of books, which were mostly detective novels by authors such
雪莉正在与她身为律师的丈夫办理离婚手续，作为和解的一部分，她将有能力购买一个新的居住地。乔治邀请雪莉随时去看看房子。几天后，雪莉前往乔治·特雷帕尔的房产参观。乔治住在阿尔图拉斯一个偏僻的地方，周围有一些橘子林。房子装饰着1970年代的风格，包括黄色的窗帘和橙色的橱柜。它有一个塞满了科学书籍的图书馆。主卧室也堆满了书，大多是阿加莎·克里斯蒂等作家的侦探小说。
as Agatha Christie. The room, which George described as his junk room, was full of crystals, rocks and minerals. Visible through the junk room window was a small, brownish-yellow coloured building. George explained it was a garage his neighbours had converted into an apartment. George had reported them to the local building board for doing so as they hadn't obtained a proper permit. The incident had caused some bad blood between George and his neighbours, who lived on the only other property in the immediate vicinity.
乔治称之为“杂物间”的房间里堆满了水晶、岩石和矿物。透过杂物间的窗户可以看到一栋棕黄色的小建筑。乔治解释说，那是邻居改建成公寓的车库。乔治向当地建筑委员会举报了他们，因为他们没有获得适当的许可证。这件事在乔治和住在附近唯一另一处房产的邻居之间造成了隔阂。
George hadn't liked them, especially because one of them had constantly tried to sell him things like a pickup truck. George said the neighbours had moved out, and were possibly trying to sell the property for way over its value. Finally, George took Sherry through his garage workshop. Inside were lots of tools and jugs of what appeared to be chemicals. Sherry Gwynne decided against buying the house, telling George it was too big for her. But she stayed in touch with George, and the two built a friendship over the following months.
乔治不喜欢他们，尤其是因为其中一个人不断试图向他推销皮卡车之类的东西。乔治说邻居已经搬走了，可能正试图以远高于其价值的价格出售该房产。最后，乔治带着雪莉参观了他的车库工作室。里面有很多工具和看起来像是化学品的罐子。雪莉·格温决定不买这栋房子，告诉乔治它对她来说太大了。但她与乔治保持了联系，两人在接下来的几个月里建立了友谊。
They chatted on the phone and met up in person from time to time. George was sympathetic about Sherry's difficult divorce and her acrimonious relationship with her ex-husband, Richard. The fact that Richard was a lawyer didn't endear him to George, who hated lawyers. George offered ideas as to how Sherry could rid herself of Richard by getting him arrested. He suggested she write a letter accusing Richard of molesting a child. Another idea was to send a threatening note to then-president George Bush and sign it with Richard's name.
他们经常通电话，并不时见面。乔治对雪莉艰难的离婚和她与前夫理查德（Richard）之间充满敌意的关系表示同情。理查德是一名律师这一事实并没有让乔治对他产生好感，因为乔治讨厌律师。乔治为雪莉提供了如何通过让理查德被捕来摆脱他的想法。他建议她写一封信指控理查德猥亵儿童。另一个想法是给当时的总统乔治·布什寄一封威胁信，并签上理查德的名字。
He joked that Sherry should send him a poisoned flower delivery. In November of 1989, George Trepal and his wife Diana left their home in Alturas and moved nearly 40 miles southeast to the city of Sebring, Florida. With their out-tourist house now empty, George told Sherry she was welcome to move in. Sherry had been living in a condominium but wanted somewhere with more space. She agreed to rent to George and Diana's property temporarily. Sherry moved in on Tuesday, December 12, 1989. She didn't see George for over a month.
他开玩笑说雪莉应该给他送一束有毒的花。1989年11月，乔治·特雷帕尔和他的妻子戴安娜离开了他们在阿尔图拉斯的家，搬到了东南约40英里处的佛罗里达州塞布林（Sebring）市。由于他们的房子现在空着，乔治告诉雪莉欢迎她搬进去。雪莉一直住在公寓里，但想要一个空间更大的地方。她同意暂时租用乔治和戴安娜的房产。雪莉于1989年12月12日星期二搬了进去。她有一个多月没见到乔治。
Then on Thursday, January 25, 1990, George received an urgent-sounding phone call from Sherry. She was in Sebring and needed to talk to him about something. Sherry asked George to meet her at a local McDonald's. A short time later, the pair sat down at an outdoor table. Sherry didn't waste any time in getting to the point. She explained that shortly after moving in to George's home, she'd received a visit from a local sheriff's deputy who was living next door.
然后，在1990年1月25日星期四，乔治接到了雪莉打来的一个听起来很紧急的电话。她在塞布林，需要和他谈谈某件事。雪莉请乔治在当地的一家麦当劳见她。不久后，两人坐在户外的一张桌子旁。雪莉没有浪费时间，直接切入正题。她解释说，在搬进乔治家后不久，她就受到了住在隔壁的一位当地警长副手的拜访。
Sherry's voice shook as she said, I think you neglected to tell me that something had happened in the neighborhood. George sounded calm and unbothered as he replied. Oh yeah, somebody got poisoned next door. George Trepell's out-tourist property bordered the house where Pie and Peggy Carr had lived. It had been 15 months since Peggy Carr's poisoning and 10 months since her death. Pie Carr and the rest of the family had moved out of the house within two months of Peggy first falling ill.
雪莉的声音颤抖着说：“我想你忘了告诉我附近发生过什么事。”乔治听起来很冷静，毫不在意地回答：“哦，是的，隔壁有人中毒了。”乔治·特雷帕尔的房产与派和佩吉·卡尔住过的房子相邻。距离佩吉·卡尔中毒已经过去了15个月，距离她去世也过去了10个月。派·卡尔和家人在佩吉第一次生病后的两个月内就搬离了那栋房子。
George Trepell had never mentioned the unsolved murder to Sherry Gwynn in all the time they'd been friends. This was odd, given his love for murder mysteries and detective novels indicated he had a strong interest in crime. Sherry was struck by the matter-of-fact tone in which George discussed Peggy's poisoning. She told him, That might not be a lot to you, but it's a lot to me. George laughed and apologized.
乔治·特雷帕尔在他们做朋友的这段时间里，从未向雪莉·格温提起过这起未破的谋杀案。这很奇怪，因为他对谋杀之谜和侦探小说的热爱表明他对犯罪有浓厚的兴趣。雪莉对乔治讨论佩吉中毒事件时那种公事公办的语气感到震惊。她告诉他：“这对你来说可能没什么，但对我来说意义重大。”乔治笑了笑并道歉。
Sherry asked if the poisoning was what prompted George and Diana to leave their neighborhood and if they were scared. No, apparently it was some sort of personal vendetta, George said. I mean, it's not like they're running around poisoning everybody. Sherry explained that some detectives had dropped by to speak with her. They'd asked about George and his whereabouts. Sherry handed the detectives business cards over to George. He suddenly felt quiet.
雪莉问中毒事件是否是促使乔治和戴安娜离开那个社区的原因，以及他们是否感到害怕。“不，显然那是一些个人恩怨，”乔治说。“我的意思是，他们又不是到处去毒害所有人。”雪莉解释说，一些侦探曾顺道来找她谈话。他们询问了乔治及其下落。雪莉把侦探的名片递给了乔治。他突然安静了下来。
He told Sherry that he and Diana had already spoken to the investigators twice. He couldn't understand why they would be looking for him now or why they would be talking to Sherry about it. I hope I'm not a prime suspect, George added. That could be messy. George Cripal and his wife Diana had problems with the car family that dated back years, long before Peggy Carr ever lived on the property. The two households had never been friendly.
他告诉雪莉，他和戴安娜已经和调查人员谈过两次了。他不明白他们为什么现在要找他，或者为什么要和雪莉谈论这件事。“我希望我不是主要嫌疑人，”乔治补充道。“那可能会很麻烦。”乔治·特雷帕尔和他的妻子戴安娜与卡尔一家的矛盾可以追溯到几年前，远在佩吉·卡尔住进那处房产之前。这两个家庭从来都不友好。
George and Diana prided themselves on their more intellectual pursuits, while Pye and his family were more salt-of-the-earth types. Back around 1984, when Pye still lived with his ex-wife, he was given a Rhodesian Ridgeback dog. The dog sometimes jumped the property's fence and chased after George's cat. Pye had seen George throwing sticks at the dog in response. One day, the young, healthy dog suddenly started losing weight and died. Pye had always suspected it had been poisoned, but didn't know who would do such a thing.
乔治和戴安娜以他们更具知识分子的追求而自豪，而派和他的家人则更脚踏实地。大约在1984年，当派还和前妻住在一起时，他得到了一只罗得西亚脊背犬。这只狗有时会跳过围栏去追乔治的猫。派曾看到乔治为了回应而向狗扔棍子。一天，这只年轻、健康的狗突然开始消瘦并死亡。派一直怀疑它是被毒死的，但不知道谁会做这种事。
After Pye divorced his wife and married Peggy, things only got worse between the neighbors. George and Diana thought the car property was too noisy. In retaliation, George disconnected the water supply for the well that the cars used. George was also unhappy about the way Peggy and Pye's teenage sons rode their motorcycles through the area, sometimes onto his property. There was a lake beside George's house, and he'd added some sand to the area to create a little beach. Pye's son Travis had once ridden his motorbike on the beach, messing up the sand.
在派伊与妻子离婚并娶了佩吉之后，邻里之间的关系变得更加恶劣。乔治和戴安娜认为汽车修理厂太吵了。作为报复，乔治切断了汽车修理厂所使用的水井供水。乔治还对佩吉和派伊的十几岁儿子骑摩托车穿过该地区，有时甚至骑到他家地盘上的行为感到不满。乔治家旁边有一个湖，他在那里加了一些沙子，造了一个小沙滩。派伊的儿子特拉维斯曾经骑摩托车在沙滩上行驶，把沙子弄乱了。
An upset George had reported the incident to Pye, who replied, kids will be kids. In October 1988, George and Diana made several complaints about how loud the car's sons were playing their radio when hanging out in the garage. While Pye was away on his hunting trip, Diana came over to complain, and a verbal altercation broke out between her and Peggy. The next day, Peggy fell ill from the poisoning that eventually ended her life. When the detectives investigating Peggy's homicide learned that a threatening letter had been sent to the family months before Peggy's death, warning them to, quote, move
心烦意乱的乔治向派伊报告了这件事，派伊回答说，孩子嘛，总是调皮的。1988年10月，乔治和戴安娜多次投诉，称汽车修理厂的儿子们在车库里闲逛时收音机开得太大声。当派伊去打猎时，戴安娜过来投诉，她和佩吉之间发生了口角。第二天，佩吉因中毒而病倒，最终不治身亡。当调查佩吉谋杀案的侦探们得知在佩吉去世前几个月，有人给这家人寄过一封威胁信，警告他们，引用原文，搬出佛罗里达，否则你们都得死。
out of Florida or else you all die. They initially wondered whether Pye car himself could have written it. It seemed unbelievable that he'd forgotten to mention it. They asked Pye if he knew of anyone who would want to harm his family. Pye drew a blank. The only people he'd had any trouble with were their neighbors, George Trepal, and his wife Diana. This was a major breakthrough for detectives.
他们最初怀疑是不是派伊·卡尔本人写的。他竟然忘了提这件事，这简直令人难以置信。他们问派伊是否知道有谁想伤害他的家人。派伊想不出来。他唯一有过节的人就是邻居乔治·特雷帕尔和他的妻子戴安娜。这对侦探来说是一个重大突破。
They were fairly confident that the car family had been targeted by an outsider instead of from within. But the remote location of their property meant it would have been incredibly difficult for someone to sneak in a poisoned carton of Coca-Cola without being seen. Someone was almost always at home, and they would have noticed if any strange cars were in the area. Whoever had committed the crime had to have struck when the house was empty. The only house with a view of the car residents was George Trepal's.
他们相当确信卡尔一家是被外人盯上的，而不是内部作案。但他们住所偏僻，外人很难在不被发现的情况下潜入并放入一箱有毒的可口可乐。家里几乎总是有人，如果附近有陌生车辆，他们肯定会注意到。无论谁犯下了这起罪行，都必须在家里没人的时候下手。唯一能看到卡尔家住所的房子就是乔治·特雷帕尔的家。
In the past, Pye's teenage daughter Tammy had received obscene phone calls when she was home alone. The caller, who sounded like an educated white male, often called right after Tammy's mother left the house. He would describe exactly what Tammy was wearing. Two days before Peggy got sick, there had been a window of time when no one was home. That same day, Dwayne and Travis had gone into the kitchen to get a coke from an 8-pack they'd noticed under a counter earlier.
过去，派伊十几岁的女儿塔米独自在家时曾接到过淫秽电话。打电话的人听起来像是一个受过教育的白人男性，经常在塔米的母亲离开家后立即打来。他会准确描述塔米穿什么衣服。在佩吉生病前两天，有一段时间家里没有人。就在那天，德韦恩和特拉维斯走进厨房，想从他们早些时候在柜台下发现的一箱8瓶装可乐里拿一瓶。
But it wasn't there. The teenagers searched several rooms but couldn't find it. The carton mysteriously reappeared beneath the counter a short time later. The back door to the car property didn't always latch properly, and could sometimes be opened when it appeared to be locked. Around the time Peggy and the two teenagers had been admitted to hospital, Pye found the back door open. A profile of Peggy's Poisoner had been built by an agent from the FBI's Behavioral Sciences
但可乐不见了。这几个青少年搜查了几个房间，但没找到。不久之后，那箱可乐又神秘地出现在柜台下面。卡尔家住所的后门并不总是能关严，有时看起来锁上了，其实还能打开。在佩吉和两个青少年被送进医院前后，派伊发现后门开着。联邦调查局行为科学部门的一名探员已经勾勒出了佩吉投毒者的画像。
Unit. The agent said that most people who choose poison as their murder weapon were intelligent individuals who liked to solve problems without direct confrontation. The agent also believed that the culprit would be an educated white man in his mid-thirties. He would see himself as intellectually superior to others. George Treepow fit the profile almost to a tee. Some digging revealed that George had a criminal record. In September 1975 he was arrested by a federal agent with the Drug Enforcement Administration.
该探员表示，大多数选择毒药作为谋杀工具的人都是聪明人，他们喜欢在不直接对抗的情况下解决问题。该探员还认为，罪犯应该是一名三十多岁、受过教育的白人男性。他会认为自己在智力上优于他人。乔治·特雷帕尔几乎完全符合这个画像。一些挖掘工作显示，乔治有犯罪记录。1975年9月，他被缉毒局的一名联邦探员逮捕。
He had been operating a large illegal methamphetamine lab in North Carolina and was involved in manufacturing the drug himself. The agent described to George Treepow as, quote, probably the smartest chemist that I've ever known. To make the methamphetamine, George used a chemical known as P2P. Although this could be bought legally, federal drug agents kept records of people who purchased it. To get around to this problem, George sometimes brewed his own P2P.
他曾在北卡罗来纳州经营一个大型非法甲基苯丙胺实验室，并亲自参与制造这种毒品。那位探员形容乔治·特雷帕尔是，引用原文，我所认识的最聪明的化学家。为了制造甲基苯丙胺，乔治使用了一种被称为P2P的化学物质。虽然这可以合法购买，但联邦缉毒人员会记录购买它的人。为了解决这个问题，乔治有时会自己酿造P2P。
Homemade P2P was sometimes made using the heavy metal thallium. After being convicted of running an illicit drug lab, George Treepow was sentenced to three years in federal prison. He was a model inmate and prison officials soon recommended him for parole. It was the night. George found himself frustrated by his fellow inmates. In particular, he hated how loudly some of them played their radios. He even sent a lengthy memo to prison officials complaining about the matter.
自制的P2P有时会使用重金属铊。在因经营非法毒品实验室被定罪后，乔治·特雷帕尔被判处三年联邦监禁。他是一名模范囚犯，监狱官员很快就建议他假释。那晚，乔治对狱友感到沮丧。特别是，他讨厌有些人把收音机开得那么大声。他甚至给监狱官员发了一份冗长的备忘录，抱怨这件事。
Not long after it was determined that Peggy Carr had been poisoned, detectives visited George Treepow at home. George sounded slightly nervous and hesitant and didn't express any sorrow for what the cars were going through. He said he didn't know his neighbors well, but they would wave and say hello when they saw each other. They're not really our kind of people, George added. When asked if he had any problems with Pie Carr and his family, George became more animated.
在确定佩吉·卡尔中毒后不久，侦探们拜访了家中的乔治·特雷帕尔。乔治听起来有点紧张和犹豫，并没有对卡尔一家的遭遇表示任何同情。他说他不太了解他的邻居，但他们见面时会挥手打招呼。乔治补充说，他们真的不是我们这类人。当被问及是否与派伊·卡尔及其家人有任何过节时，乔治变得更加激动。
He complained that Pie had always tried to sell him things like a barbecue pit made from a 50 gallon drum. The detectives asked to George what he knew about thallium. He said he knew nothing at all, except what he'd heard on news reports about the case. Why would somebody want to poison the Carr family, one of the detectives asked. It was the standard question they'd been asking everyone they spoke to in relation to the case. The details of the threatening letter had never been made public.
他抱怨派伊总是试图向他推销东西，比如用50加仑油桶做的烧烤架。侦探们问乔治对铊了解多少。他说他一无所知，除了从有关此案的新闻报道中听到的。为什么有人想毒害卡尔一家，其中一名侦探问道。这是他们问每一个与此案有关的人的标准问题。威胁信的细节从未公开过。
Most people said they had no idea why or suggested the culprit must have hated the family. But George's answer was unique. He nodded his head towards the Carr property and said, to get them to move, like they did. George Treepow was becoming an increasingly likely suspect, but with no physical evidence linking him to the case, it was decided that he should be put under surveillance. Detectives recruited a colleague at the Polk County Sheriff's Office to help with the task. Susan Gorak was 33 years old and had previously worked undercover on a number of drug related
大多数人说他们不知道为什么，或者暗示罪犯一定很恨这家人。但乔治的回答很独特。他向卡尔家的方向点了点头，说，为了让他们搬走，就像他们做的那样。乔治·特雷帕尔成为越来越可能的嫌疑人，但由于没有实物证据将他与此案联系起来，决定对他进行监视。侦探们招募了波尔克县治安官办公室的一名同事来协助这项任务。苏珊·戈拉克今年33岁，此前曾在多起毒品相关案件中从事卧底工作。
cases. The investigation into George Treepow was dubbed Operation Pale Horse, a reference to an Agatha Christie novel in which the killer murders his victims with thallium. Agent Gorak spent several weeks reading up on George Treepow and observing him as he went about his daily business. She and a colleague also searched a dumpster outside of his office looking for incriminating evidence, ideally something linking him to a thallium supplier. But nothing was found.
对乔治·特雷帕尔的调查被称为“苍白马行动”，这是指阿加莎·克里斯蒂的一部小说，凶手在小说中用铊杀害受害者。戈拉克探员花了几个星期的时间阅读关于乔治·特雷帕尔的资料，并观察他的日常生活。她和一名同事还搜查了他办公室外的一个垃圾箱，寻找罪证，最好是能将他与铊供应商联系起来的东西。但什么也没找到。
After Peggy Carr died, detectives decided they needed to try a different approach. They would assign an undercover agent to get close to George in the hopes he might confide his secrets. They thought a woman would be best, as George would view her as non-threatening. Susan Gorak was given the task. She constructed her alter ego, a divorcee named Sherry Gwynne. Knowing that George Treepow hated lawyers, Agent Gorak decided her fictional ex-husband would be an abrasive attorney.
佩吉·卡尔去世后，侦探们决定尝试一种不同的方法。他们将指派一名卧底探员接近乔治，希望他能吐露秘密。他们认为女性最合适，因为乔治会认为她没有威胁。苏珊·戈拉克被委以重任。她塑造了自己的化身，一个名叫雪莉·格温的离异女性。由于知道乔治·特雷帕尔讨厌律师，戈拉克探员决定她虚构的前夫是一名尖酸刻薄的律师。
She would flatter George and earn his sympathy by discussing her marital problems with him. A Mensa murder mystery weekend that George was hosting was Agent Gorak's inn, and she sent him a letter posing as Sherry asking to attend. Over the course of that weekend, Agent Gorak looked for clues and took numerous photographs. She took particular note of a pamphlet George had written up for the weekend, which was titled Voodoo for Fun and Profit. The title was a nod to the theme of the murder mystery, which centered about Voodoo practitioners. An excerpt of the pamphlet read,
她会奉承乔治，并通过与他讨论婚姻问题来赢得他的同情。乔治正在举办的一个门萨谋杀之谜周末活动是戈拉克探员的切入点，她以雪莉的名义写信给他，要求参加。在那个周末，戈拉克探员寻找线索并拍摄了大量照片。她特别注意到了乔治为周末活动写的一本小册子，标题是《巫毒：为了乐趣和利润》。标题是对谋杀之谜主题的致敬，该主题围绕巫毒教从业者展开。小册子的一段摘录写道：
Few voodooists believe they can be killed by psychic means, but no one doubts that he can be poisoned. When a death threat appears on the doorstep, prudent people throw out all their food and watch what they eat. Hardly anyone dies from magic. Most items on the doorstep are just a neighbor's way of saying, I don't like you, move or else. To investigators, this appeared to be a not-so-subtle reference to the poisoned Coca-Cola bottles that appeared at the car home. Over the course of eight months, Agent Gorak built a friendship with George. She complained to him about her fictional ex-husband, hoping it might coax a confession out of him.
很少有巫毒教徒相信他们会被心理手段杀死，但没有人怀疑他们会被毒死。当死亡威胁出现在门口时，谨慎的人会扔掉所有的食物并注意饮食。几乎没有人死于魔法。门口的大多数物品只是邻居表达我不喜欢你，搬走否则后果自负的一种方式。对调查人员来说，这似乎是对出现在卡尔家门口的有毒可口可乐瓶的含蓄指涉。在八个月的时间里，戈拉克探员与乔治建立了友谊。她向他抱怨她虚构的前夫，希望这能诱使他坦白。
The undercover operation was a long, slow process. Eventually, the higher-ups began complaining about the lack of results. Then, a breakthrough finally occurred when George and his wife moved to Sebring in November 1989. Agent Gorak would ask to rent their home in Al-Turus, giving her unfettered access to the property. Agent Gorak moved into George Treepower's home on Tuesday, December 12, 1989. That evening, crime scene technicians descended on the property. They rubbed cotton balls dipped in nitric acid along surfaces throughout the house, looking for traces of thallium. Sinks, drains and the inside of cabinets were all swabbed.
卧底行动是一个漫长而缓慢的过程。最终，上级开始抱怨缺乏成果。然后，当乔治和他的妻子于1989年11月搬到塞布林时，终于取得了突破。戈拉克探员要求租下他们在阿尔图拉斯的房子，这让她可以不受限制地进入该房产。戈拉克探员于1989年12月12日星期二搬进了乔治·特雷帕尔的家。那天晚上，犯罪现场技术人员涌入该房产。他们用蘸有硝酸的棉球擦拭整个房子的表面，寻找铊的痕迹。水槽、排水管和橱柜内部都被擦拭取样。
The garage workshop was also searched. George hadn't bothered to clear it out when he moved. Empty spray paint cans, scraps of wood and garden supplies were littered everywhere. The floor was covered with sawdust, nails and broken glass. There were also jugs filled with various liquids. A couple of small bottles were found on George's workbench. One was made of brown glass and had a white residue inside. These were packaged up to be examined at an FBI lab.
车库车间也进行了搜查。乔治搬走时没有清理它。空喷漆罐、木头碎片和园艺用品到处都是。地板上覆盖着锯末、钉子和碎玻璃。还有装满各种液体的罐子。在乔治的工作台上发现了几个小瓶子。一个是棕色玻璃做的，里面有白色残留物。这些被打包送往联邦调查局实验室进行检查。
While investigators were waiting for the results to come back, Agent Gorak met with George, as Sherry, to tell him that she knew about the poisoning next door. She hoped that he might be shocked into giving something away. Although George seemed rattled, he didn't say anything incriminating. In March 1990, one year after Peggy Carr's death, the results from the property search came back. The brown bottle found in the garage workshop had tested positive for thallium. At 8am on Saturday, April 7, 1990, Agent Gorak dialed George Trepal's home number in Sebring from a mobile phone. When George came to the phone, Agent Gorak said in a shaky voice,
当调查人员等待结果时，戈拉克探员以雪莉的身份与乔治会面，告诉他她知道隔壁中毒的事。她希望他能因为震惊而泄露一些东西。虽然乔治看起来很慌乱，但他没有说任何有罪的话。1990年3月，在佩吉·卡尔去世一年后，房产搜查结果出来了。在车库车间发现的棕色瓶子检测出铊呈阳性。1990年4月7日星期六上午8点，戈拉克探员用手机拨打了乔治·特雷帕尔在塞布林的家中电话。当乔治接电话时，戈拉克探员用颤抖的声音说：
Hi George, it's Sherry. Those two investigators came to my house again this morning. They were asking about you again, something about chemicals. I don't know what they're talking about. Do you? George told Agent Gorak to calm down as she grew increasingly distraught. The two chatted for a while, then Agent Gorak heard a disturbance on George's end. In a calm tone, George suddenly said,
嗨，乔治，我是雪莉。那两名调查员今天早上又来我家了。他们又在问关于你的事，说是关于化学品的。我不知道他们在说什么。你知道吗？当戈拉克探员变得越来越心烦意乱时，乔治让她冷静下来。两人聊了一会儿，然后戈拉克探员听到乔治那边有动静。乔治突然平静地说：
Sherry, by coincidence, the police are here. You'll have to call back Monday. While Agent Gorak had been talking to George, investigators had been making their way to his home, armed with a warrant for his arrest. George's wife Diana tried to refuse their entry and had to be pulled from the doorway to the front yard. Diana yelled and swore at the police, but George seemed relaxed as he met them at the top of the stairs, wearing only a pair of women's bikini briefs. He got dressed and was then placed under arrest for the murder of Peggy Carr. Meanwhile, investigators carried out a search of George's sea-bring residence. Amongst his belongings, they found a loose-leaf binder filled with pages taken from scientific textbooks.
雪莉，巧合的是，警察来了。你得周一再打来。当戈拉克探员与乔治通话时，调查人员带着逮捕令前往他的家。乔治的妻子戴安娜试图拒绝他们进入，不得不被从门口拉到前院。戴安娜对警察大喊大叫并咒骂，但乔治在楼梯顶端迎接他们时显得很放松，只穿了一条女式比基尼内裤。他穿好衣服，随后因谋杀佩吉·卡尔而被捕。与此同时，调查人员搜查了乔治在塞布林的住所。在他的财物中，他们发现了一个活页夹，里面装满了从科学教科书中撕下的页面。
George had written a title on the front. General Poisoning Guides Inside, the binder featured information for law enforcement on identifying poisoning cases. Another book titled Poison Detection in Human Organs had a detailed paragraph on thallium. A large amount of bondage equipment and toys were found in a closet. In another room, a secret compartment behind a pegboard lined with tools revealed a tiny, sound-proofed room. It had black-panelled walls and no windows. On the floor was a wooden platform the size of a bed with manacles attached.
乔治在封面上写了一个标题：通用中毒指南。在活页夹内，收录了供执法部门识别中毒案件的信息。另一本名为《人体器官中的毒物检测》的书详细介绍了铊。在一个壁橱里发现了大量的束缚设备和玩具。在另一个房间里，一个衬有工具的钉板后面的秘密隔间里露出了一个微小的隔音室。它有黑色镶板墙，没有窗户。地板上是一个床大小的木制平台，上面系着手铐。
It looked as though the room had only recently been built and testing revealed nothing untoward, such as blood or other bodily fluids. But it looked to detectives as though George had been making a torture chamber with the space to tie someone up. News of George Tree Powell's arrest came as a shock to his fellow Mensa members. They told the media they couldn't believe that such a great guy would be capable of murder. To them, George was a friendly man who rescued stray cats. Peggy Carr's children were also in disbelief that their eccentric former neighbour could do such a thing, especially over something as minor as loud music. George Tree Powell pleaded not guilty and his trial began in January 1991.
看起来这个房间是最近才建成的，测试显示没有异常情况，比如血液或其他体液。但对侦探们来说，看起来乔治一直在利用这个空间建造一个折磨室，用来把人绑起来。乔治·特雷帕尔被捕的消息让他的门萨成员感到震惊。他们告诉媒体，他们无法相信这样一个好人会做出谋杀这种事。对他们来说，乔治是一个救助流浪猫的友好男人。佩吉·卡尔的孩子们也不敢相信他们古怪的前邻居会做出这种事，尤其还是因为音乐声大这种小事。乔治·特雷帕尔拒不认罪，他的审判于1991年1月开始。
FBI scientists testified about the way Peggy had been poisoned and the bottles with traces of thallium found in George's home. Agent Susan Gorak was the state's star witness. The day after she testified about her undercover work on the case, George's wife Diana approached the agent outside the courtroom and screamed, I hope you know just what a bitch you are. George Tree Powell's defence team argued that the evidence against their client was entirely circumstantial. They pointed to other possible suspects whom they felt investigators hadn't considered, such as George's wife Diana. They also queried why detectives had been so quick to rule out Peggy Carr's husband, given that the couple had been having marital problems. They cited a Jack Daniels bottle that was found in the Carr's shed and was filled with some sort of pesticide.
联邦调查局的科学家作证说佩吉是如何中毒的，以及在乔治家中发现的带有铊痕迹的瓶子。苏珊·戈拉克探员是州政府的明星证人。在她就此案的卧底工作作证后的第二天，乔治的妻子戴安娜在法庭外接近该探员并尖叫道：我希望你知道你是个多么贱的女人。乔治·特雷帕尔的辩护团队辩称，针对他们客户的证据完全是间接的。他们指出了调查人员认为没有考虑到的其他潜在嫌疑人，例如乔治的妻子戴安娜。他们还质疑为什么侦探们如此迅速地排除了佩吉·卡尔的丈夫，因为这对夫妇一直有婚姻问题。他们引用了在卡尔家棚子里发现的一个杰克丹尼酒瓶，里面装满了某种杀虫剂。
Health officials had never tested the pesticide, so couldn't say whether or not it had thallium in it. A search of the Carr's garage apartment had also revealed a trace of thallium beneath the sink. However, the state pointed out that this trace had been so minuscule that a second test of the sink found no thallium at all. It was possible the first test had been a false reading. The trial ran for four weeks. The jury ultimately found George Tree Powell guilty of 15 charges, including one count of first-degree murder and six counts of attempted first-degree murder. At the jury's recommendation, George was sentenced to death by lethal injection. 32 years later, George Tree Powell remains on death row.
卫生官员从未检测过这种杀虫剂，因此无法确定其中是否含有铊。对卡尔家车库公寓的搜查也在水槽下发现了铊的痕迹。然而，州政府指出，这种痕迹非常微小，以至于对水槽的第二次测试根本没有发现铊。第一次测试可能是读数错误。审判持续了四个星期。陪审团最终裁定乔治·特雷帕尔犯有15项罪名，包括一项一级谋杀罪和六项一级谋杀未遂罪。根据陪审团的建议，乔治被判处注射死刑。32年后，乔治·特雷帕尔仍被关在死囚牢房里。
He is now 74 years old and maintains his innocence. All of his appeals have been unsuccessful. To this day, some people believe that George Tree Powell is innocent. His supporters point to the circumstantial nature of the case against him and maintain that detectives had tunnel vision from the start. They describe George as a gentle man they've never known to be violent. But investigators, including Agent Susan Gorak, who spent a year getting to know George Tree Powell, have no doubt that the man dubbed the Mensa murderer is guilty. In 1995, Agent Gorak co-wrote a book about the case with the journalist Geoffrey Goode.
他现在74岁，坚称自己无罪。他所有的上诉都失败了。直到今天，有些人仍然认为乔治·特雷帕尔是无辜的。他的支持者指出了针对他的案件的间接性质，并坚持认为侦探们从一开始就有思维定势。他们形容乔治是一个他们从未听说过有暴力倾向的温和男人。但包括花了一年时间了解乔治·特雷帕尔的苏珊·戈拉克探员在内的调查人员毫不怀疑，这个被称为门萨杀手的人是有罪的。1995年，戈拉克探员与记者杰弗里·古德合著了一本关于此案的书。
Titled Poison Mind, the book details Agent Gorak's undercover work as Sherry Gwynn and examines the impact that the case had on Peggy Carr's family. Peggy's children drifted away from their stepfather Pie Carr and his kids. They all have mixed feelings about George Tree Powell's death sentence. Pie Carr told the Ledger newspaper that he's still waiting for the day when he can see the death sentence carried out. Quote, I still want to be there when he's executed, but I don't have anything to say to him. I don't think I could control myself if I was to talk to him.
书名为《毒心》，详细介绍了戈拉克探员作为雪莉·格温的卧底工作，并审视了此案对佩吉·卡尔家庭的影响。佩吉的孩子们逐渐疏远了他们的继父派伊·卡尔和他的孩子们。他们对乔治·特雷帕尔的死刑判决有着复杂的情绪。派伊·卡尔告诉《分类账》报纸，他仍在等待死刑执行的那一天。引用原文，我仍然想在他被处决时在场，但我没什么话要对他说。如果我和他说话，我想我无法控制自己。
Two of Peggy's children, Dwayne and Jelena, say they have forgiven George Tree Powell and don't believe he should be executed. But Peggy's son, Alan, disagrees. He believes that George losing his life is the consequence he must suffer for his actions. Alan, Jelena and Dwayne have all found their own ways to keep their mother's memory alive. Dwayne had to battle with physical trauma as well as emotional pain. The poisoning that took his mother's life also led to Dwayne losing half his body weight and spending three months in hospital. He had to use a wheelchair until he could walk again. Although he eventually made a full recovery, he struggled in the aftermath.
佩吉的两个孩子，德韦恩和杰琳娜，说他们已经原谅了乔治·特雷帕尔，不认为他应该被处决。但佩吉的儿子艾伦不同意。他认为乔治失去生命是他必须为自己的行为付出的代价。艾伦、杰琳娜和德韦恩都找到了各自的方式来铭记他们的母亲。德韦恩不仅要面对情感上的痛苦，还要与身体上的创伤作斗争。夺走他母亲生命的毒药也导致德韦恩体重减半，并在医院住了三个月。他不得不使用轮椅，直到能再次行走。虽然他最终完全康复，但在那之后他过得很艰难。
While going through some difficulties, he found strength in writing a letter to Peggy. Today, he wishes his mother was still alive so she could meet his wife and see how he's turned his life around. Alan thinks of Peggy anytime he sees a waitress whose apron pockets jingle with the sound of coins. Whenever Jelena wants to connect with her mother, she says aloud, Mama, I love you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在经历了一些困难时，他从给佩吉写信中找到了力量。今天，他希望母亲还活着，这样她就能见到他的妻子，看到他如何改变了自己的生活。每当艾伦看到围裙口袋里发出硬币叮当声的女服务员时，他就会想起佩吉。每当杰琳娜想与母亲联系时，她都会大声说，妈妈，我爱你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。